[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing a character who has one of
the worst reputations
in the entire franchise behind perhaps
only umbridge
pettigrew cornelius fudge and her
husband
i am of course talking about petunia
dursley
aka petunia evans petunia evans was an
english muggle woman the daughter of mr
and mrs evans
the sister of lily evans and the aunt of
harry potter
despite her obvious despicable nature
the cold-hearted
evil petunia that we're introduced to in
the books and films
wasn't always so bad in fact nearer the
beginning of her childhood
she was actually just a normal young
girl that got along with her sister
the same sister that she would later
despise the pair grew up
in the town of cokeworth close to the
town of spinozzend
where snape grew up and as they grew
older petunia's sister lily
began to show more and more signs of
magical ability
where petunia did not lily's magical
accomplishments
started off quite small and though
petunia didn't think much of them at
first
she eventually began to feel the onset
of jealousy as
lily's magic grew stronger she received
a considerable amount of attention
from her parents for her gifts and i
think that petunia
who had none just felt left out though
petunia was jealous at this stage
she didn't yet hate her sister however
in the year 1971
that would change as it was the year
that lily received her letter to
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
it was a momentous occasion for the
family most of them anyway
the youngest daughter of the evans
family was a witch
when petunia saw lily receive her letter
she felt a rush of emotions
confusion anger but most of all jealousy
and despite not being magical she felt
compelled to write a letter
to none other than albus dumbledore
hogwarts headmaster
hoping to be a part of the magical
school herself petunia stated her case
to dumbledore
and asked if she could study there with
her sister however
given that petunia was not magical in
any way dumbledore had to politely
decline in petunia's request
to attend the school though she was
declined entrance for a good reason
petunia felt hurt and left out and on
this day
the jealousy that petunia felt toward
her sister reached new
darker heights from that day onward
petunia denounced magic
entirely it was a world that rejected
her and the pain that she felt from her
rejection
manifested itself in the form of anger
toward her sister
whom she would now refer to as a freak
oh
she got a letter just like that and
disappeared off to that
that school and came home every holiday
with her pockets full of frogs born
turning teacups into rats i was the only
one who saw her for what she was
a freak but for my mother and father oh
no
it was lily this and lily that they were
proud of having a witch in the family
in the 1970s petunia eventually left
coke worth in pursuit of a career in
london
this is when she first met her would-be
husband vernon dursley
the bane of harry's existence and one of
the foulest men
in the entire franchise now disgusted
with the completely bizarre world of
magic petunia sought the opposite
the ordinary and in vernon she certainly
found it
vernon was a particularly narrow-minded
man and the majority of their dates
were comprised of vernon ranting and
expressing a shallow outlook on the
world around them
however nonetheless the pair bonded over
their
normalcy and the pursuit of normalcy it
was the union of two people
who came from very different backgrounds
but both cherished the mundane
and the predictable vernon provided
petunia with the stable
safe environment that she sought after
and petunia provided vernon with an
outlet
an ear that he could complain to as
their relationship progressed
vernon proposed and petunia recognized
that she would eventually have to tell
vernon
about the whole magic thing something
which she was sure she would have strong
opinions about
her main concern was that it would hurt
his perception of her but when she told
him
she realized very quickly that it was
quite the opposite it was something they
could bond over
one day petunia confessed to vernon that
her sister was in fact
a witch unsurprisingly vernon had a low
opinion of magic
and the magical world almost immediately
and
after some discussion they eventually
bonded over petunia's sister lily
being a freak after petunia and vernon
had wed
they simply moved forward with their
lives pretending that lily
had never existed at all mrs potter was
mrs dursley's sister
but they hadn't met for several years in
fact mrs dursley pretended she didn't
have a sister
because her sister and her
good-for-nothing husband were as
undurslish as it was possible to be
eventually petunia and vernon even had a
son
dudley and they were insistent from the
beginning that
despite knowing that her sister lily had
a son as well they would not have deadly
fracturing with him
vernon and petunia did everything in
their power to live the most ordinary
vanilla boring life possible but when
lily and james potter were murdered in
the magical world would arrive right
their doorstep
whether they liked it or not james and
lily's brutal murder at the hands of
voldemort
meant that the dursleys were now
responsible for taking care of baby
harry
however though they raised harry i'm not
sure that
care is the right word for the treatment
that they gave him
instead of celebrating harry's magical
background the dursleys hated harry for
it
and even worse than that they hid it
from him they hated any and all things
that weren't normal
and they were unusually cruel to him an
innocent young boy
whose parents had been murdered they
forced him to live in a cupboard under
the stairs
put bars on his windows tried to prevent
him from going to hogwarts
and told him that his parents had been
murdered in a car crash
they were horrible to harry but one
thing that i can't accept at face value
in the harry potter franchise
is that petunia truly blindly hated
harry she was bitter
full of resentment and jealousy and
determined to banish anything magical in
nature from her life
but had she not met vernon dursley a
particularly intolerant man
i'm not sure that this attitude would
have been perpetuated
to the extent that we see in the books
and films did petunia make harry's life
a complete misery
yes but was she truly rotten to the core
or was she just a damaged person
with a sort of tragic existence there is
one passage from the deathly halloweds
that alludes to all of this and really
sticks out to me she stopped and looked
back
for a moment harry had the strangest
feeling that she wanted to say something
to him
she gave him an odd tremulous look and
seemed to teeter on the edge of speech
but then with a little jerk of her head
she bustled out of the room
after her husband and son in an
interview rowling actually explains what
this meant
i think that for one moment she trembled
on the verge of wishing harry luck
that she almost acknowledged that her
loathing of this world
and of him was born out of jealousy but
she couldn't do it
years of pretending that normal was best
had hardened her too much
she had convinced everyone even herself
that she hated the magical world
but petunia's deepest darkest secret was
that she wanted to be a part of it
perhaps more than anything else she
lived this ordinary life with this
ordinary man
in an ordinary home but deep within her
heart petunia always had a strong pull
towards the exceptionally unordinary the
magical not only that
but petunia also secretly loved the boy
but she always tried to give the
impression of outwardly hating
harry was the son of the sister that she
lost and loved
he was her family but in order to cope
with her own jealousy and bitterness
she told herself no time and time again
no
i do not care for this boy rowling had a
little more to say on this
petunia had some latent feelings of
guilt about the way she had cut lily
whom she knew in her secret heart had
always loved her
out of her life but these were buried
under considerable jealousy
and bitterness petunia had also buried
deep inside her
and never confessed to vernon her long
ago hope that she
too would show signs of magic and be
spirited off
to hogwarts so there you have it petunia
dursley
one of the most hated people the entire
harry potter franchise
was really just a damaged person who
couldn't cope with the card that she had
been dealt
in a way despite all the terrible things
that she did to harry
i sort of feel bad for petunia she felt
neglect when her parents devoted their
attention to lily's
magical nature and she felt rejection
when dumbledore informed her
that there was no way that she would be
able to tend hogwarts
she was a little girl who likely felt
stunted in the way that she would be
able to express herself
as nothing would compare to magic and
this jealousy manifested itself in the
worst way possible
sending her down a dark path and that's
it for this video
what do you guys think does this change
your perception of petunia
at all or is she still just the same
lady that made harry's life hell
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you